una función f x esta gráfica de abajo
resalta un intervalo donde la primera
derivada de f de x sea menor que cero y
donde la segunda derivada de fx sea
menor que cero también que la primera
derivada de fx sea menor que cero me
dice que la función tiene que ser
decreciente ahora en esta gráfica
tenemos un máximo aquí y un mínimo acá y
la función solo es decreciente entre
esos dos puntos entre este máximo
y este mínimo de por acá tengo que
seleccionar un intervalo por ahí por
otro lado que la segunda derivada de fx
sea negativa quiere decir que la
pendiente está decreciendo la pendiente
de la línea tangente así que por ejemplo
aquí tengo el máximo en donde la
pendiente vale cero y aquí la pendiente
es negativa y cada vez se está haciendo
más negativa hasta que llega un punto
donde la pendiente comienza a crecer
para regresar a cero en este punto
entonces bien otra cosa que podríamos
observar es que esta condición que la
segunda derivada de f en el punto x sea
menor que 0 nos dice que la función
tiene que ser cóncava hacia abajo en ese
punto y la función es precisamente
cóncava hacia abajo en este segmento de
aquí así que voy a seleccionar este
intervalo
y en efecto estamos en lo correcto muy
bien hagamos otro una función fx de
nuevo esta gráfica de abajo resalta un
intervalo donde ahora la primera
derivada va a ser positiva pero la
segunda derivada va a ser negativa
entonces que la primera derivada sea
positiva quiere decir que la función es
creciente así que estamos lidiando entre
el límite izquierdo de la gráfica y este
máximo por aquí y del mínimo que está
por aquí a el lado derecho de la gráfica
bien ahora que la segunda derivada sea
negativa me dice que la función debe ser
cóncava hacia abajo en ese punto noten
que aquí la función no es cóncava hacia
abajo en cualquiera de estos la función
es cóncava hacia abajo y de hecho se
puede verificar que en estos puntos la
pendiente de la tangente se está
haciendo más grande cada vez parece más
una línea horizontal listo así que yo
apostaría a que es un intervalo por aquí
muy bien ojalá ustedes pueden hacer los
demás ejercicios solos